hey cinephiles welcome to another
exciting edition of incident trailer
review today we're talking about
interstellar and what an interstellar it
is that line made more sense of my head
Christopher Nolan's new movie obviously
they're exciting it's very interesting
to be able to do a trailer review for
the last movie ever to be shot on film
apparently you know everyone's up in
arms about on the end right looks very
exciting it is soo big so let's dress
and I saw it on the big screen last
night before Godzilla which is how they
premiered this and I can highly
recommend seeing it as big as you can
this weekend McConaughey must seem
gigantic oh god agree he's never been
bigger um now they mentioned it's an
Indian drone in this makes me think like
what what are the politics of this movie
gonna be cuz it's it's one of those you
know like in the far future America
before most power on earth is super poor
and India sending drones into Indiana
it's you know it's one of those like
alright this is the way we we make
ourselves the underdog yes in the future
also it must be middle America because
they're driving through a Gorn that's
true
all right little mama says he's gonna
continue um this is really executive
he's gonna lead a sci-fi movie like this
you know then again you know the science
fiction movie of ideas hopefully this
can measure up to contact a movie yeah
that's McConaughey it was in before the
Makana hands began while we're looking
at this Paramount logo once it's just
reminisce about this really quickly
because this film used to be in SPO
Burke's laughs yeah for a long time a
girl and then it fell into Nolan's hands
yeah apparently through Jonathan Nolan
who Spielberg came to for rewrites and
when he backed off the Nolan's got yeah
hey I got a pretty good hold brother
but then Warner Brothers wanted a piece
of that pie so with a deal they gave me
Friday the 13th and the park yeah I know
hopefully we'll see more of those so
yeah it's a joint distribution I would
love to be an interstellar meets Friday
the 13th maybe they can send Jason to
space or something that would be really
interesting I just I would love to see
that
Mackenzie boy I think is okay actress
playing a little girl who was in the
conjuring quite like during them great
child actors and she's struggling to
know why she's named Murphy apparently
in early versions of the script that was
a boy okay but even proves it that much
I'm still gonna get picked on yeah
now Michael Caine doing the Michael
Caine dialogue trailer I think he did
similar stuff for transcendence you know
but if you gotta give expository trailer
dialogue right an actor make that actor
Michael Caine I would like to I would
like him to officiate at my funeral
if at all possible I think your timing
is wishful yeah you know on his part
Wow I'm guessing the walls just
separated and a rocket was behind there
all the time that's super cool room
opens right up on the launch pad I was
fine and this is the first moving image
that we got from the teaser where he's
crying very giving it yeah all right so
the music for this by the way
V for Vendetta and okay it's it's a
great piece of music I wasn't a huge fan
of that movie I frankly like it Morris
it's really good received when
soundtracks from other movies wind up in
trailer down sometimes to better use
alright so the crew is going down you
know while they're going on and again so
much of oh there we go Jessica Chastain
my personal pet theory this is
McConaughey's young McKenzie boy played
daughter but grown up so this is adult
Murphy so this is adult Murphy okay
Makana has been gone from Earth yeah
what 20 years maybe well yeah that's a
long time so you know
but she looks great you would swear he'd
been gone for this part really is just
amazing I mean it's honestly like you're
thinking of like 2001 and you know even
sequences from the tree of life at this
point well it's all good thing and it's
very funny how earthbound be the initial
news we were getting from this movie
cause it was all about you know oh
there's not enough corn and you know it
got some derision on the internet I
think that I mean this is the kind of
sequence that like this movie's gonna be
in IMAX right it's apparently it's gonna
have the most footage shot in IMAX of
any straight narrative you know a major
theatrical Wow
so I cannot wait to see something this
big and it looks very 2000 and not in 3d
at all yeah if I'm sure if Nolan has his
way no 3d you know releasable Avery and
the couch is really exciting more sort
of vaguely 2001's imagery
you know he's gonna be having a lot of
flashbacks this whole time - I sort of
hope this is not like a tree of life
you know scattershot narrative type
thing I think it'll be a little more
straightforward but one of the
consultants on the film camp recalled
the name but he's a black hole
you know wormhole Theory okay guy and
apparently quite a few of his sort of
non-traditional theories have to do with
time travel as relates to like
gravitational warp and all that so it's
very interesting maybe we'll get some
kind of Starchild return yeah maybe he's
gone for ten thousand years again you
know like this is if if this is the the
movie it looks like it is it's you know
heir to a long tradition of you know big
idea sci-fi like two paths one like
contact I mean we can all hope that this
is the new inheritor of that torch so
this is the first official full-length
trailer now let me just say I wish this
is all we would see
we did we get to the take-off and the
rest is like a complete mystery yeah but
I doubt very much that any company
that's putting the amount of money down
if I know these two Studios they're
gonna release lots of clips I mean
there's gonna be probably four more
trailers yeah if if you want to go into
this cold which you know is a great idea
I think it's gonna be a difficult road
the last couple of months to avoid all
the material but I'll be coming out
around this movie but might be worth it
so I'll try one way you try the other
okay that's it they're gone in a flash
so interstellar it looks fantastic yeah
let us know what you think about this
trailer in the comments below let us
know if you would like to see more
promotional material or less because I'm
thinking grants for Less who on the
Internet
punk scene new things that's a good
point but me I think of like The Dark
Knight Rises when we saw that Stadium
set piece and I couldn't get that image
out of my head and when I saw the movie
I was like okay I already know what's
gonna happen here it takes away from the
soldier there in the moment so if you
would like to take on the entire studio
system as its evolved to sell tickets
and get people to see movies please let
us know the comments below
if not we will see you the next time
something foreigner sheller or the next
giant release comes down I'm Sam and I'm
Jas thanks for watching